I am so happy and thrilled to be here
with you today for look educated I have
to tell you that I was I this is one of
the most extraordinary memoirs that I've
ever read so I am honored to be here
with you today to talk to you about it I
really I was blown away by this and
actually reading it for a second time
actually even made my experience with it
even that more profound so thank you so
much it's really great to be here
so I wanted to just dive right in and
what I want to do is ask you to read a
bit from the preface so I'll let you
take that turning toward our house on
the hillside I see movements of a
different kind
tall shadow stiffly pushing through the
currents my brothers are awake testing
the weather I imagine my mother at the
stove hovering over brand pancakes I
picture my father hunched by the back
door lacing his steel toed boots and
threading his calloused hands into
welding gloves on the highway below the
school bus rows rolls past without
stopping
I am only 7 but I understand that it is
this fact more than any other that makes
my family different we don't go to
school dad worries that the government
will force us to go but it can't because
it doesn't know about us 4 of my parents
seven children don't have birth
certificates
we have no medical records because we
were born at home and have never seen a
doctor or nurse we have no school
records because we've never set foot in
a classroom when I am nine I will be
issued a delayed certificate of birth
but at this moment according to the
state of Idaho and the federal
government I do not exist
of course I did exist I had grown up
preparing for the days of abomination
watching for the Sun to darken for the
moon to drip as if with blood I spent my
summers bottling peaches and my winters
rotating supplies when the world of men
failed my family would continue on
unaffected
well that is quite an opening and I want
to start there I want to start in Bucks
Peak Idaho where this takes place where
your childhood took place can you tell
me a little bit touch on some of it but
take me through a day in the life of
what it was like as a a ten year old
version of yourself buck speak well we
have the farm which belonged to my
grandfather so it was really beautiful
there were a lot of wild wheat fields
and then it was the basest mountain and
so bucks peak is the name at the
mountain and it was this it wasn't a
particularly big mountain but it was
just really beautifully made you know it
sort of came up out of the earth and and
formed into a really perfect spire and I
had always been told this beautiful
story about the mountain that every
spring when the snows began to melt that
there would be the image of a woman's
body that would appear on the mountain
face a my dad called her the Indian
princess and he had this story that the
nomadic Indians would look for her sign
as look for her coming as a sign that
spring had ended and that the winter was
over and it was time for them to come
back so it was a really beautiful place
the farm my dad owned a junkyard which
was full of crumpled up cars and we
played in it it was very exotic kind of
playground there was a lot of beauty in
my childhood I think it took me a long
time to realize that there were that
that it wasn't completely normal because
to me it seemed very normal and then now
I'm older I can see there were elements
of it that that were probably unusual
you know so my dad was opposed to a lot
of the institutions that most people
just take for granted
so public education doctors and
hospitals anything to do with the
government
and what that meant was that I was never
allowed to go to school or to the doctor
and I and I didn't have a birth
certificate until I was nine years old
yeah I mean you know there's this kind
of it's the kind of interplay between
this idyllic existence right you're
running around kind of free in this
environment that seems very foreign to
me as a city kid and it seems almost
this magical place but and I've heard
you kind of talk about this that it
there's an other there's the other side
and there were very much two sides to
your childhood experience yeah
absolutely so the mountain was beautiful
I would say everything that
that had one side - I had another so my
mother was an herbalist and a midwife
and so she we would spend all these
hours walking on the mountain gathering
bowline and and rose and rose hips so
she could turn into tinctures so all
these beautiful things but all of them
had another side to it so the junkyard
was this exotic playground but we also
got hurt in it quite a bit there were a
lot of injuries like the time my my
brother let its leg on fire and it was
covered in Burns and we made the
decision to treat it at home because my
father didn't believe in doctors or
hospitals so in a situation like that
even something like the herbalism which
was this wonderful thing that my mother
was really talented at could be a bit
scary when you're dealing with a real
injury that you know you don't have
morphine or things like that could you
speak a little bit about your father's
philosophy I mean I and I attribute it
to your father more than your mother
though they did share in the philosophy
but it seems to me reading the book it
came mostly from your father is that
fair to say I think it was mostly coming
from him I mean it's a complicated thing
sometimes I think it was a kind of
spiritual doctrine that he had and
sometimes I think it was he was he had
this theory that all these institutions
the government public education that
they had been infiltrated by some kind
of ill meaning organization sometimes he
called it the Illuminati or the New
World Order or what-have-you so I think
his reason for opposing these things is
because he believed that they were
trying to do us harm
and he really believed it I don't think
he was it was you know it was a real
conviction that he had there's a lot of
fear there I mean do you have any but if
you could actually pinpoint what was he
afraid of
really from these Illuminati from these
different kind of sources but what was
the fear where was the fear based I
think it depends on which institution
you're talking about I think doctors I
think he was concerned that what he
called the medical establishment that
they weren't actually doing good that he
believed that a lot of the things that
people take drugs for example any kind
of pharmaceutical what would would
damage your body you know that the
effects would last for years and also
that they would damage you spiritually
and that you really you should
you should use natural healing you know
herbs he called them God's pharmacy so I
think it was specific to each thing I
think with public education he was
worried that it was that it was
brainwash that you know it would kind of
lead us away from God and that kind of
thing so it kind of depends on which you
know he's a complicated person that's
like everybody's complicated I mean I
know brainwashing seems to be a big part
of what he was talking about there and
he fear of you being brainwashed of you
know the Illuminati coming in and
brainwashing I think that's you know a
part of it is is the fear of I guess
someone coming in and changing the path
that he has set for his children I guess
I mean it is that part of the fear is
this kind of outsider I think so inside
our perspective he had really specific
ideas about things and I think he was
worried that we might go to a doctor and
that we might kind of in some way
compromised our health our spirituality
I think he you know in his mind the kind
of the path was was narrow and you
needed to do these exact things in order
to stay in good standing with God in
order to do these in order to to be a
good person and all these things so I
think I think that was a fear that you
could just easily get sucked into the
world you know this this idea of the
world in the world being well worldly
and that means bad thing and I think a
lot of people have that idea I think
it's a strong idea and a lot of
religions but for my father it just
included doctors right right I mean it's
you were Mormon but it's it's not a this
is not a Mormon perspective of
mainstream Mormonism at all yeah most
Mormons almost all Mormons you know they
they support education they either most
Mormons send our kids to school or they
believe in homeschool but they really
believe in it or they're you know or and
they definitely believe in doctors and
things so it's not representative of
Mormonism at all no and I found that
interesting than your preface that you
said this is not I mean you wanted to
make that point I think I did because I
think that right now the political
environment is so polarized and I think
people will latch on to any story they
can to confirm their own preconceptions
about something and I think that my dad
had some irregular idea
I think he had I think that the way his
mind worked and I I'm not a medical
professional so I don't know what it was
but I I felt like maybe he had some kind
of mental irregularity and I just in my
mind the religious extremism I think was
a vehicle for that so I would say
whatever was happening in his mind I
think caused the religious extremism I
don't think it was the other way around
and I don't want people to take this
story and say well look all religious
people are like this or all Mormons are
like this or we knew that these other
people who are different from us and
it's really easy with people that are
different from you to just make them
into a caricature and I didn't want that
to happen well let me tell you from
reading the book that is not the
takeaway at all and I am this is a
foreign land to me you know in many ways
and that is not to take away at all so I
think you can rest assure that that's
not gonna be a problem
now you know you you do talk I mean what
what is interesting to me is you know
the idea of kind of people taking from
no popular culture what's going on the
news I'm kind of applying it to their
worldview and there was an example of
that that you called your first memory
that is not a memory which is of the
Ruby Ridge Massacre he talked a little
bit about that and and that role in
shaping kind of some of some of the
fear-based belief that that your father
kind of espouse to his children can you
talk a little bit about that yeah so he
did have these ideas about the
government and that the government
especially I think around the time of
the Ruby Ridge incident our family
wasn't so different from the Weaver
family in the way that we lived in the
kind of being a little bit isolated and
you know we didn't go to school and all
of that so I think when that happened to
them my dad there was a period where my
dad was quite worried that it could
happen to anyone
which isn't a completely irrational
thing to take I mean if it's happened to
someone else but I was I was about 5
when that happened and so we kind of
went into this period where we were
caning a lot and and we were just we
were preparing we got these bags that we
were gonna if we needed to run and hide
in the mountain we were gonna have them
I I have a you know I I had a journal
entry from one a few years later when I
still had this bag and I documented all
the contents you know
pages of like you know heater for the
emergency food and water purifiers and
mosquito nets and just all the things
that you would need if you were gonna go
live on the mountain and I had them in
this bag so for me that that event I
don't know how long it lasted for my dad
maybe it was a blip but it lived in my
mind as this is this very frightening
thing that made me feel like the
government could come at any moment and
he never told us the end of the story
you tell this will you tell a bit about
the story just yeah so I mean The
Weavers were this family and they lived
in Idaho and they the way that it began
was I believe it had to do with a a
conflict over a rifle
that Randy Weaver had sold apparently to
an undercover ATF agent at an Aryan
Nations gathering and he missed a court
date I think and then they big the FBI
and the federal marshals began to do
some surveillance and somehow there was
a conflict where a dog was shot and then
an agent was shot and then the the son
Randy Weaver's I think he was 11 and it
just got out of hand very quickly and it
ended up being a Randy Weaver was shot
when visiting his son's body the agents
that surrounded the cabin and ultimately
Randy Weaver's wife Vicky was shot while
holding their baby she was killed by a
sniper so it was a horrendous story and
that was the version that I was told
that my that my dad told us look what
could happen look what could happen to
us and I remember having you know dreams
where I would we would be crawling
around on the floor because there were
snipers outside so really lived in my
mind in this way but because he didn't
really tell me the end of the story so
when I was 17 I was at a university and
then I I heard the end of the story and
I heard how there had been this massive
public outcry and there had been
congressional inquiries and newspapers
you know every major newspaper had
covered this story and it became a
different story when I was a child it
had become a story about how frightening
the government was and how they were
gonna come for us and it was a secret
thing that I thought only we knew about
I don't know how I thought I knew about
it but obviously then I realized I mean
it was a terrible thing that happened
but there were checks on
I mean that's how a democracy works in a
lot of ways and it's it wasn't something
that was kept a secret it wasn't covered
up it was it was very much a public you
know there's massive public outcry so
part of the fear of that's right I mean
as a five-year-old that story is
terrifying you know especially in a
situation you were in where you were you
very much identified with that family
but so you kind of feel that the idea
that you you weren't alone and that
knowledge at your family wasn't alone
and that knowledge would have been
comforting to you had you known that
when you were that young do you think I
think if I had just had an understanding
of how the institutions themselves had
responded you know that it wasn't like
the government wasn't this wholly evil
force but obviously that was an incident
over the abuses of power and a callous
disregard for human life I think one of
the I think that might be what the
Congressional report on it said and I
think that is a very different idea of
government that people that there is a
Free Press that people find out about
things that there are checks and
balances I mean when I went to
university I didn't just learn the end
of the story of Ruby Ridge I also
learned how the Constitution works and
what are the checks and balances on the
system and what is the role of the Free
Press and that you know that changes the
way that story felt quite a bit that's
really interesting to me so I want to go
back to what I like to think of it is
there are kind of three stages of your
education this book and I'm assuming
that's why you kind of call educated and
I can you talk a little bit about the
education that you learned with your
family and and you know it's not a
traditional education but what are you
not at all but I mean tell me some of
the value of the things that you you
learned as a child there that that most
people in this country probably haven't
haven't learned well so all right my
parents believed in home school and when
my older brothers were younger I think
that my mother did a pretty decent job
of home schooling the time I came along
she had seven kids she was a midwife she
was an herbalist there was a farm there
wasn't a lot of home-school going on so
I never read an essay for my mother I
never took an exam there was never
anything like a lecture anything like
that so the home school that I received
was pretty limited in terms of formal
education but there is one thing that I
really valued from what my parents
just the way that they raised us and
they had this philosophy and they would
say it to us all the time that you can
teach yourself anything better than
someone else can teach it to you and I
really it's just a principle I really
agree with and I worry a lot that in
when we talk about education in this
country and I live in England all I
think there too it's become something
that is really passive and there there
should be an I think an individual
component to it and not just a social
component if it if it's just social it
is a bit propaganda and I think people
need to they need to feel actively
engaged I think in designing their own
curriculum and I I do think to some
level we I hate the word disempower it
sounds a bit cliche but I do worry that
a lot of people seem to have really
taken to heart this idea that to learn
something you have to have a degree and
you have to have a whole institution in
place to teach it to you and I'm I'm
grateful to my parents that I was not
raised to think that so when I decided I
wanted to go to college when I was 16 it
felt like something I could do not
because I had any formal education but
just okay I need to learn algebra I will
buy a book and I'll learn it and I
didn't do an amazing job I kind of
barely got the university but I kept
going with that and I think yeah my
parents took it too far
I arrived at university really
underprepared and you know I once raised
my hand in a class and asked what the
Holocaust was I'd never heard of it and
people thought I was being anti-semitic
I think they thought I was denying it I
wasn't I never heard of it before so I
wouldn't say this is the ideal education
I would not say that but I do think they
I think they had something there about
people feeling ownership over what they
learn because if you think of education
I think a lot of people talk about
education as a way to make money as a
way to get a better job
but the way I experienced it was it's
about making a person it's not about
making money it's about making a person
I think everyone should have that
opportunity to participate in the making
of their own mind and I just think it
needs to be a more active and people
need to be more involved I think in
their own education how did the way you
were raised helped you write this book
do you think I mean obviously in a very
literal sense but in terms of I mean the
actual act of create
book it's not easy yeah and I didn't
know how to write narrative I literally
had not written a word of narrative when
I decided to write this book and I had a
PhD cuz I once I got to school I had
really committed and I ten years later
after I you know I set foot in a
classroom the first time when I was
seventeen and ten years later I
graduated from Cambridge with a PhD so I
knew how to do academic writing by then
it took me ten years but I figured it
out
I didn't know how to write prose and its
really different but I think it was that
same principle i sat down so this is a
scale I want and what are the ways that
I can get it one of the ways I can learn
and the thing for me that made the
biggest difference was the New Yorker
fiction podcast which is amazing because
you just have really great writers come
on and they read the stories of other
great writers and then they explain to
you how they work and it's an amazing
curriculum but more to the point it was
a curriculum that worked for me and so I
could pursue it and I didn't have to
spend a lot of time pursuing a
curriculum that didn't work for me
because I think everybody is different
which is why I think that curriculum you
make for yourself it's always gonna be
better than what other people will make
for you were there any any books that
were particularly helpful to during the
creation of this book well when I
started writing it I had never read a
short story and I think I've never heard
of short stories I didn't know what they
were but I found short stories so
helpful um there were a lot of books I
wrote a lot of Joan Didion I read a lot
of searching towards Bethlehem in the
Year of Magical Thinking I read a lot of
Toni Morrison because she's a genius
and then a ton of short stories you know
David means like just yeah I could go on
and on but there's so many great writers
but I think you you take the ones that
speak to you and there's some amazing
writers that I enjoy reading but they're
nothing like I write and they don't give
me ideas about how to write and then
there are some writers that that do and
I think that's the beauty of having
control over how you learn so back to
your childhood um what were you reading
then I read a lot of
of religious books we had other books in
the house but it didn't really read them
mostly what I read I read The Book of
Mormon I read the Bible and I read a lot
of 19th century speeches by the kind of
founding Mormon prophets so that was a
language I was I was at home in pretty
quickly it's pretty interesting when you
went to school for the first time at 17
at BYU you wrote in this kind of stilted
archaic style is that correct yeah I
wrote in a very stilted style because
that was that was what I'd been reading
and I think a lot of my professors were
just very bewildered by why I sounded
like it you know 19th century yeah yeah
I took a while to kind of get that that
voice out it's something amazing that
the writing voice is often so different
than the talking voice and that you had
to really work on you didn't speak in
that way he didn't speak and that
stilted way I'm assuming isn't that
interesting that that was the part that
you really had to kind of I think a lot
of people have this out of writing where
they they feel a certain
self-consciousness about writing and I
think sometimes when we feel
self-conscious we become more formal yes
and I've noticed this in a lot of
writing not just my own that people will
use words like establishment instead of
building or store you know words that
you would never you've never used
because I think they feel like they
sound more human somewhere intellectual
or something so I had that but I just
had a really bad case of it because of
all I think century books I read how
long did it take you to get that kind of
exercise that well I wrote the whole
book the first draft in about a year and
I would say the first four months
everything I wrote was absolutely
terrible so about four months are you
being hard on yourself or with it right
now particularly with false modesty bad
really bad I took it to your writing
group once and yeah they were I mean I
was lucky because I didn't really think
of myself as a writer I was literally
trying to learn to write because I
wanted to write this one book and so I
didn't have it it wasn't a part of my
identity when they said this is really
terrible I said yeah I know of course it
is I'm not a right
and just tell me how to make it better
and so that was actually a really
wonderful place from which to learn how
to riot because I had no personal
feelings about it at all so the ego was
not yeah I didn't think I was a writer I
didn't there's no reason I should know
how to do this I've never lit erally
never written a word of story before but
I'm going to try to learn and so it was
yeah I was a really great place
interesting to me is that you journaled
for a good portion of your life when did
you start journaling and talk up a
little bit about those journals that you
have I have a couple of journal entries
when I was 8 but I really get serious
about it and I was about 10 and then I
was very faithful about it and and I
have all of them you know whole stack -
2 or 3 stacks what do they look like I
made all different kinds or they're
really different they're all very a lot
of them were given to me by my
grandmother and they tend to be yeah
they tend to have a picture of Jesus on
them actually almost all of them I would
say up to the age of 16 and then they
just become black was that what was the
act of for you I know I'm a journal or
as well well for me it's about kind of I
don't think I really understand
something until I write it down
what was your active of writing why were
you doing it do you have an idea of why
I think that there were a couple reasons
I think I think that was a bit of
loneliness there I sometimes when I read
those entries I detect I mean I didn't
have a lot of friends I didn't have any
friends actually there was another
family lived in my town who were like my
family and that kids didn't go school
and they didn't believe in doctors and
so I would occasionally see this one
other girl but all the kids in our town
I never went to any of their houses I
was never invited I was always pretty
isolated I think I had my siblings but
but you know I think I wanted friends
and so I think I would write in this
journal so I could tell someone and all
my stuff and I think that was one
reasons I think there's probably a
processing element to it and I don't
know it I don't know other than that I
don't really know why I did it but I
really latched onto it I'm mad and
you're grateful for them now I having
written this book
they were probably indispensable they
were really really helpful yeah they
were yeah
do you still journal now I do yeah you
know who knows what's next right but so
I'm you know what's interesting to me
again up going back to your childhood
was for me a big part of something I did
not recognize in my own and there are
many things but was
like physical pain threats of physical
pain that I mean in childhood we skinned
my knee and we hurt ourselves but I mean
you were in a junkyard you know there's
a there's a part where you have this
accident in the junkyard who would you
talk about that a little bit yeah so my
dad ran a junkyard um and he I don't
know why but for whatever reason he just
didn't have that bone in his head that
would tell him this is a dangerous thing
do not do this thing and then even after
someone had been hurt he didn't always
understand how serious it was and I
think he kind of thought that everything
that happened happened for the best and
that we were gonna be protected so he
didn't really believe in safety
equipment in in the traditional sense
you know we would build these big
buildings we'd be standing on beams so
we didn't have safety harnesses we
didn't wear safety hats it was a very
dangerous place and I don't think it's
because he didn't care about our safety
I think he did care about our safety I
just don't think he understood how
dangerous it was and then even after it
would happen and there was one example
of that when I was probably around 14 my
we were just I was filling up a bin full
of scrap metal and then when the bin was
full the idea was it had to be picked up
by a forklift on a JCB which is a
forklift with an extendable boom and
then it had to be taken over and dumped
into the semi-trailer its massive
trailer and so I filled up this bin and
I said to my dad okay let's dump the bin
and he he wanted someone to go into the
the big bin the trailer and settle the
scrap after he dumped it he decided that
it would be faster if I rode up in the
bin scrap and then he said I'll hold it
level with the trailer and you can kind
of crawl out and then skimming over to
the cab where you'll be out of the way
of the falling metal and and
everything'll be great and I was
terrified I was not in the habit of
disobeying my dad so I got in the bin
and when he was he picked up the bin and
as he was turning to rotate around to
where the trailer was a bit
of a bit of scrap just came loose and it
had a really jagged edge and it just
pierced through my leg like like a knife
going into butter and it just pinned me
in place and I couldn't move so he he
had the bin it was level he was waiting
for me to crawl out I was trying to
shout down to him that I couldn't move
but it was a really loud diesel engine
and he couldn't hear me and so then he
starts raising it up and I know he's
gonna dump this bin and I'm inside it
and it's gonna be like going through a
meat grinder I mean 2,000 pounds of
falling scrap metal luckily when the
scrap started to fall the thing came out
of my leg and it fell and I was able to
throw myself over the side so I fell to
the ground and I hit the side of the
trailer but I was I was injured but I
was okay and I just remember at the time
feeling really I think I first
experienced anger that he'd let it
happen
but that dissipated really quickly and
after that I just felt kind of ashamed
it seems like a it seemed like a simple
thing and I didn't know why I hadn't
been able to do it and I think what I
was missing in that moment I I knew that
my dad would never hurt me on purpose I
didn't have that information that that
there might be something going on in his
head where he could you know value my
safety but not be able to keep me safe
you know that there might be an
explanation besides this is my fault
because I knew he would never hurt me
and yet somehow I'd gotten hurt so it
had to be me and I think as children we
experience events in this way and and
it's so easy to internalize it and
internalize guilt and I had to be much
older I think before I could look back
on that event and not feel ashamed about
it and then I think there was a period
where I was just really angry at my
father
how could you those happen to me how
could you bend this kind of father and
then I think now where I mad as I feel
like I feel like now I have all the
pieces and I can put it together and say
he would never wanted to let me get hurt
however for whatever reason he isn't
able he wasn't able to run the scrapyard
any other way he wasn't able to
understand the risks of the way he was
doing things
now I'm just blown away by your the fact
that you're not angry I mean you know so
many people are angry at their parents
you know I sometimes minor you know
transgressions you know but this is a
pretty major one and you seem to not
really hold any anger towards him I have
a theory about anger
I think anger is important I think it's
a mechanism that the brain uses to keep
us from going back to situations or
people that will harm us but I think I
think there's a risk with anger as well
because if you if it takes over too much
of your life I think it can be really
consuming and I mean spoiler alert I I
am estranged from my parents and that
circumstance was was really hard they're
really hard things that happened that
led to the outcome and for a long time
after that happened I was full of rage
every beautiful memory I had for my
childhood was completely it just turned
to rot and I became a person who had no
beautiful memories whose whole life was
rage and I just think I think you need
anger maybe to get you out of these
situations but then once you're out once
you're safe I'm not sure you do need it
and I kind of wonder if you can just get
rid of it and live a better life without
it I think if I still had my my family
in my life I would need my anger I would
need it every day but but now I don't
feel like I need it particularly and
it's been important for me to reclaim
the beautiful parts of my childhood so
to remember that yes scrapyard was
frightening but it was also fun and yes
my father let those things happen to me
but he would never have wanted that to
happen and there were wonderful things
about him too and so I think it's a
delicate balance because I would never
want to take the good things about them
and say oh I'm just going to only focus
on the good and dismiss the bad things
because you let yourself get hurt or you
let someone else get hurt but then you
see but you don't want us over the bad
either so I aspire to this idea of kind
of mental integrity which just means
that to me anyway it means that no one
can take from either good but no one can
obscure from me the bad
and that's what I mean when I say I just
want to live in my own head and I don't
I want to have a grasp on the reality as
it is and I don't want to get consumed
with with anger that blocks out the
wonderful things about a person but I
also don't want to expose myself to risk
by not recognizing their limitations
this sounds extremely evolved and are
you in therapy or have you come to this
on your own a lot of therapy I think I
think I had to come to a lot of on my
own but I have done a lot of therapy but
I think it's something I think therapy
is really helpful because it never feels
like it is that's the tragedy of it it
never feels helpful but I do you think
it is because you set aside this time to
think about how you feel and do you want
to feel that way and I have spent a lot
of time in therapy thinking about how
angry I feel and realizing I don't want
to feel that way but I also don't want
to go back so what's what's the middle
road right was this book an active was a
catharsis or did it bring a lot of these
things back it ended up being cathartic
I didn't think it would be I thought I'm
sorted but um it was I think because for
one thing the bits of it that I thought
would be hard to write about which were
the kind of more traumatic bits we're
actually not very hard to write about I
feel like I had before I started writing
I'd really reconciled with the bad
things in my life the danger of the
scrapyard I had a violent older brother
I felt like I'd kind of reconciled with
that what I had to reconciled yet war
the beautiful things so the way the
mountain looked the way that my mother
would laugh when she was canning peaches
the good things about my father and the
good things even about my older brother
I think those were the things that I had
loved about my childhood the most and
those who have things that I had lost
and it was it was hard actually that was
the hard thing was being really close to
these things I was never gonna have
again and I think that ended up being
the hardest thing to write about but I
think in a way a good thing because it
let me reclaim a bit of that in a
strange way I'll never really be able to
reclaim it but I every claimed it in
this other way is there one part of the
book that was particularly hard to write
that surprised you
there are a couple moments about my dad
that were hard to write about there was
a moment where my brother saves my life
basically we're breaking in horses and I
was on a horse that went completely
berserk and he was on a horse that had
never had a rider on it before it had
never been ridden it was his first time
and my horse went into a fit and I got
my foot caught in the saddle and it was
bucking and it was running and it was it
was on a hillside and it ravines
everywhere it was really just a matter
of time before I fell off and was
dragged and that's pretty much game over
your head hits on a rock and it's done
and my brother somehow on this
completely unbroken horse managed to
catch hold of my horse and and slow it
down and this is the brother who was
quite violent who was very manipulative
who was very controlling who would at
other times twist my wrist behind my
back and call me a [ __ ] but he had this
this wonderful side and I think what
took me a long time as I kind of said
before is you can't for me it was always
tempting to say he is kind he can be
sensitive he can be really wonderful and
I still think that but I don't want to
use those things to dismiss the fact
that he could be manipulative cruel even
even violent yeah I wanted to talk about
Sean and and I was wondering if that was
hard for you to talk about but it seems
you're pretty open I think when I've
kind of reconciled with me yes kind of
varying it it was I mean there I had to
put down the book because it's it's
really hard to read it very violent and
also like psychologically violent as
well so it's not just the physical
violence you it was a psychological
torture and in some ways with him I
found the psychological I think people
fix it on the physical and I actually
tried not to dwell in the physical very
much because to me it was not the
important part I have a this idea that I
think all of us-- no matter what kind of
abuse it is i think its foremost an
assault on the mind because if you're
going to abuse someone i think you have
to invade their reality in order to
distort it and you have to convince them
of two things you have to convince them
that what you're doing isn't that bad
which means you have to normalize it you
have to justify it rationalize it and
the other thing you have to convince
them of is that they deserve it and the
second thing i think is actually pretty
easy to convince people of because
people tend to internalize that kind of
guilt when they're hurting but
first thing the first thing is hard and
my brother was was pretty good at it he
could in a matter of minutes convinced
me that something had not happened that
that had happened you know two minutes
before and he could just convince me to
have a completely different
interpretation of it and one example of
that I when I was 17 I brought this this
young man home name was Charlie after
Thanksgiving dinner and I think my
brother I think he just felt some need
to demonstrate this control over me in
front of this this person and so before
the meal had even started he grabbed me
by my hair and he haul me down the
hallway and he shoved my head in the
toilet and later when it was all over he
he told me that it had just been a game
and that you know next time we were
having fun I should really be be sure to
tell him if I was in any pain cuz he
said I had no idea I thought you're
having a really good time and I
completely took that perspective on
board 100% so much so but I actually
tried to convince Charlie of it and he
knew what he had seen but he also I
think knew that reality had no had no
bearing on me I he could see that how
far under how much under my brother's
power I was and he tried to reason with
me for a while and then and then didn't
I could just see you know but then there
was another incident a couple months
later and I've been at university for a
while and I think going to university
really helped me learn how to hold on to
my own ideas my own opinions and it gave
me the ability to say I disagree with
something and a few months later it
happened again and I my brother attacked
me in a parking lot and then that
evening when it was all over he came
into my room and he said I'm really
sorry we were just having a good time
and I had no idea that I didn't hurt you
so next time we're having fun make sure
you speak up if if you're if you're in
any pain and after he left I was writing
in my journal and I wrote that I didn't
know which version to believe but I
wrote down my version I wrote that I'd
been terrified
I wrote that I'd been in pain I wrote
that in that moment if I'd been able I
would have torn him apart and so I had
these two versions in my mind and I
didn't in that moment necessarily say
well mine's right in his is wrong I
didn't know if
he'd experienced it as a game but I knew
I had not experienced it as a game and I
think that was an important moment
because it was the first time I think
that I didn't immediately see seed my
reality to someone else's and I think it
was the first time that my brother
attempted to dominate me and at the end
of that process there were still two
Minds present two distinct minds not one
mind having gained control over another
that's really I mean you know it's
almost like a testament like you're
putting this down as this is your
experience and there were times before
in your journal from weight that you
include in your book where you're still
engaging in what you call reality
bending right you know and you say
things like Shawn he was so much nicer
to me before the accident he had an
accident and you said something to the
effect of well he was my best friend
before and he was so wonderful to me
before now he's mean and then you go
back and you realize no he was he was
violent and and an abusive before the
accident and it was almost as if you
were playing this game with yourself
well I had to I had to I had revised in
my mind he had a really serious head
injury he fell when he was working for
my father he fell off a pallet and he
was a really serious head injury he
nearly died and I had revised when that
accident took place because we were we
expected he might be violent after that
accident but I had just somehow in my
mind told myself that happened when I
was very young and that that explained
everything and it was actually when I
was writing the book I got my own
journal and I talked to my brothers who
also kept journals and sitting out if I
got the date on this wrong how is this
possible
I need it turned out that it happened
when I was much older I think when I was
17 and that was 16 I think I was 16 and
that was just but I I suddenly thought
that doesn't explain any of it
then yeah because it had been going on
for so much longer than that and that
was hard I mean even that night that
things happened with Charlie when he was
there that day with Thanksgiving I mean
I have emails I wrote to him that night
saying he would never hurt me and not
not not not after the head injury before
the Hendrie but you know he would never
he would never hurt me and I was writing
this I had a broken toe my Arora my
wrist was in a sling like and I was
saying oh that he would never do this
thing that he don't
they done so I think I think it's hard
to underestimate how powerful that that
reality distortion is and I think it's
not just the person who's experiencing
it I think anyone who's living in
proximity to these kinds of
relationships is to some degree subject
to the reality bending that goes on to
justify it you can actually say enabling
that reality bending in the way I want
to get back to that but I do want to
talk about memory this leads nicely into
the kind of questions that you you kind
of flirt with in the text about memory
and putting this book together it seems
like it involved interviewing with a lot
of people and putting putting together a
lot of different sources and trying to
kind of ferret out the truth right what
what really happened what are your
thoughts on that and and what are your
thoughts on the reliability of your own
memory now having done all this I think
it's it's a difficult thing because you
don't want to overly rely on your memory
but you don't want to be vulnerable to
people coming in and you know my family
culture had a culture of justifying
rationalizing there was a lot of that
term gaslighting denying things that
were happening kind of almost as they
were happening and I think we were also
affected by it so deeply affected by it
that it could become really difficult to
sort out but luckily you know there were
my you know my brothers were really
wonderful they're really helpful and
then they're it's nice in-laws are a
wonderful thing because they come in
from the outside and they see things
through different eyes and they're a lot
less vulnerable I think to some of those
distortions that that happen so I think
having memory is complicated I think
sometimes the stories that spring up in
families that that maybe they're right
maybe they're wrong but I think
sometimes those narratives themselves
can tell you quite a bit
oh yeah I mean I think it's so
interesting I mean how much do you think
now you touch on this as well I mean you
know explicitly actually you talk about
your father's mental health and though
you know you're not it's like I address
however you know there are things in the
that you experienced firsthand that
would lead one to believe that there was
an instability there and there was a
moment when you're in a psych 101 class
at BYU and you hear about bipolar
disorder and this kind of turns a light
on in your mind and you think this
sounds like
father I think it was my whole idea of
mental illness before I took that class
I thought you just had to be raving
lunatic you know you wear fruit on your
head and fall in love with cat that was
my idea of it
so what that class did is it gave me
another category another way to think
about mental health and the brain and
I'm not a medical professional I have no
idea but I do feel like there's a gap
between the fact that my father loves me
and yet we could be so terribly hurt by
the things that he did you know
physically especially there was just
there was some irrational decisions he
made about how to do things and I know
that it wasn't malicious so having that
other category helped me it helped me
understand that sometimes people do the
best they can and that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean everything's okay it is
that having that label does it provide
some kind of comfort that you think
again because it seems as if at least
when you were a child you were kind of
subsuming some of that like some of that
shame you were you're kind of focusing
on yourself I'm the one who course it
was you know when you describe that
experience in the junkyard you are the
one who is wrong not your father does
hearing this kind of outside label or
perspective from the mental health kind
of perspective on this that helped it
helped so much because it helped me go
back and re-experience that and have
empathy for my dad also for myself it's
a very hard thing to have empathy for
yourself especially you know your
younger child self to kind of think I'm
sorry what happen to you that shouldn't
have happened to you yeah and but I
think it's a really important step of
healing to let yourself off the hook for
those kind of feelings that you've been
carrying around is this this might be a
cheesy question I have to ask if you
could talk to yourself when you were 10
is there something you would say in
particular to yourself you know no I
don't know I kind of think and this is
gonna be cynical sorry to be cynical to
your to your like heartfelt question I
don't think there's anything anyone
could have said to me that would have
made any difference I mean one of the
things Charles said to me that night
with my brother
I was telling him it wasn't that night
it was a little bit later we ended up
breaking up because I was just too
dysfunctional basically to be in a
relationship and one of the things he
said to me he basically said I can't you
know he was 17 I'm just a kid in high
school I can't this is out of my league
this is way over my head and he said to
me I can't change this for you you can
you're the only one that can make this
better and I think that's true I don't
think there's anything that I could say
or anybody else could say to my 10 year
old self that would move move the needle
at all I think it was something I had to
come to terms with and I think that's
true of the eventual estrangement for my
family which was an incredibly difficult
decision and there were a lot of years
that I was searching every story every
film every novel for permission to make
the decision I've made the permission to
cut my father out of my life and
eventually I kind of realized no one is
going to give you that permission you
have to give it to yourself and the one
thing that did change our path it sounds
like is your brother Tyler and in
several times but the first time is when
he introduced he introduces you to music
and also when he kind of shows that
college is a possibility it probably
wasn't even in your idea of a future I
mean what was your idea of the future
prior to - you know Tyler going off to
college what did you think my parents
especially my dad had the strong belief
that a woman's place and home so you get
I always thought I would get married
when I was 17 or 18 maybe 19 and you
know put a house on the farm have kids
that was kind of you know homeschooled
oh maybe probably be a midwife like my
mother working the herbs that was very
much how I thought my life would go
until I was 16 and my older brother
Tyler who had educated himself and got
himself into university came home and
said I think that you should try to do
this yeah I mean some of the most
incredible parts of the book or when you
go to BYU for the first time and you're
outside of your family really for the
first time and on your own for the first
time and and of existing it as an adult
when you've never stepped in foot into a
classroom before he talked a little bit
about those those early days and and
what that must have been like but what
did you look like that and how did you
act and can you kind of describe that
for me probably acted quite strange
um I I definitely acted you know I
didn't feel like I belonged to my family
really quickly but I also didn't belong
there either
I'd never spent any time with what I
would have called public school kids you
know kids who went to the public school
I'd never been friends with mainstream
Mormons right you know and so for me
they lived in this way that I thought
was quite life centrist even though they
were very observant Mormons because they
drank Coke or the women would
occasionally wear like a tank top or on
the flat around the apartment and things
like that that I just was appalled by so
I didn't really necessarily and turn to
a fellowship immediately with people
because I was a bit weird I didn't have
the greatest hygiene my housemates had
to sit me down and kind of say well most
people wash their hands after they go to
the bathroom and that was my money dad
had always taught us like my grandmother
my mother's mother used to get after him
for this cuz we never did and then and
he would always say to her oh no I don't
I don't teach my kids to wash their
hands after they go to the bathroom I
teach them not to piss on their hands
and I thought that was a great
philosophy which my house my you know my
new roommates did not think I was a
great philosophy so no I didn't I didn't
fit in I felt very outside and I had a
hard time even once I started to fit in
a little better I made a few friends and
I was doing okay in school it was really
hard but I was I was gonna I was making
it and I was even more confused because
in a way then I would go back to Idaho
and I would I would have all my
mainstream friends and it would seem
more not to go to the doctor even though
I never had but all these things were
becoming more normal then I would go
back to Idaho and I would watch the way
my family lived and it would feel
completely for and at the same time
utterly like familiar and you know when
my dad he he gets really injured my nice
my third year where he is standing next
to a car trying to take a fuel tank off
and rather than then taking it off any
other way he does it with a cutting
torch on a spark from the torch makes it
into the fuel tank which he hasn't
drained and the car explodes and he was
burned horribly his whole upper half of
his body just so many third-degree burns
my family made the decision to treat it
at home and I remember you know they
used to salve that my mother had of
comfrey and lobelia and they had no
morphine and he almost died there was a
part there was a moment where I thought
he had died and I kind of closed my eyes
and started praying and trying to say
goodbye and said I was sorry that our
relationship had been so full of
conflict but he didn't die but even
though he didn't die there were months
it was months of this healing process
and there was so much pain and the whole
time I was at war with myself I didn't
know whether I thought they were right
and this is what God wanted them to do
or whether they were insane and they
were torturing him for no reason
yeah I mean that's a huge step that you
experienced when you when you go away
and you kind of see a different
perspective do you remember in school I
mean I need to talk about learning about
the Holocaust and and not knowing about
the Holocaust and how everyone was kind
of shocked about that and probably
didn't believe that you didn't know
about it
were there other examples that you can
remember of things that you know looking
back you're kind of embarrassed that you
didn't know then or so many things you
know all those kind of stories where
someone's talking about Queen and you
think they're talking about that Queen
and right so every I would say 90% of
what people said to me casually about
anything with pop culture I would just
oh yeah right really it's almost like an
alien life-form like I don't know what
they were saying the language saying
really yeah yeah smile not exactly I did
a lot of smiling and nodding in in terms
of I mean school though I'd never heard
of the civil rights movement and that
was I'd heard of slavery but I
definitely learned it from a very
different perspective I think then you
know reading accounts of slavery from
slaves like Frederick Douglass was
really eye-opening for me because I had
never had that perspective of it but it
was really the civil rights movement I
really blew my mind but that happened
and that it was so recent and I realized
that you know my mother had been a child
when this was happening and it wasn't so
far in the past you know that time could
be measured it could be measured in the
wrinkles on my mother's skin you know it
wasn't measured in geological time
really really recently and that that did
that didn't really blow my mind you end
up going to Cambridge actually go
Trinity first we'll go Trinity first did
you have an experience of of imposter
syndrome late when you were when you
were there I mean it sounds like a
little bit what you're describing you
know you're you're kind of a professor
kind of show chooses you and as a person
who he feels has a lot of potential yeah
he really helps me there was a study
abroad program that went to Cambridge
and he applied because he told me I
should and then I didn't get in and he
wrote them and said I think this person
is learning a lot she's really behind
but I I really think she'll catch up and
we should give her a chance and they and
they did so I owe him a lot for that I
mean what have you talked to him about
that and what he saw in you no no never
imagined a comfortable way I have never
you didn't do that interview for the
book yeah I mean I wrote him what I I
sent him what I'd written and said what
do you think but now I didn't I didn't
ask I have no idea but while abroad that
first time in the beginning you describe
a little bit of imposter syndrome like I
don't belong here
you know these people are different you
know but there seems to be there's this
turning point where I think it is at
Trinity where you start hearing about
positive Liberty and you're reading
about all these different ideas and at
some point he's kind of right in the
book you're like I belong that happened
there I mean did you really feel that I
think I still probably felt like I
didn't belong at that moment but I was
really interested in the ideas I was
learning I was really interested in yeah
it was hard not to be excited by what I
was learning because it was so
interesting and then I was going through
a lot of changes so when I learned I
went to this lecture on positive Liberty
I think was my first week when I came to
Cambridge as an actual Cambridge student
so the study abroad program and then I
applied and I got in as a real you know
I Sten stably belong here and I've my
first week I went to this lecture and
that lecture really blew my mind because
the whole point of Isaiah Berlin's
negative and positive Liberty is this
idea that yes there are external
obstacles that people have that keep
them from doing things if you're tied up
you can't
do something but positive Liberty says
that there are obstacles that that
people have to them doing things that
are internal they exist only in the mind
so if you're tied up you may not be able
to go outside but also if you believe
that someone outside is gonna shoot you
and there isn't someone like that it
doesn't matter whether they're there or
not you still can't go outside and so
this idea that what might be the most
important thing in determining how much
freedom you have an ability you have but
that might be in your own mind that had
never occurred to me and it was around
this time that a friend of mine sent me
this song by someone of course I've
never heard of because I've never heard
of anyone many times five Bob Marley
okay and I got really obsessed with that
lyric in terms of hate yourselves for
yourself for mental slavery yeah
emancipate yourself from mental slavery
none but ourselves can free our minds
and I became really obsessed with that
and then I ended up on Wikipedia reading
about Bob Marley and I read about the
cancer that he'd had on his toe and how
these doctors had told him that he
needed to amputate the toe but he had a
Rastafarian belief in a whole body so he
didn't and what happened was he died and
he was young and when I was reading that
I I realized that I had stopped
believing
and my dad's view of doctors and
hospitals I I told myself I had but I'd
never had my vaccinations and it and I
called and I and I got them I got all of
them I left the I left the hospital
looking like a pincushion I had them all
in one day and it took me quite a long
time to convince the nurse that I really
didn't need all of them but it was yeah
it was a moment where I kind of realized
yeah I have renounced that old world
view the old view of the world but I
haven't quite found the courage to live
in this new one but there is a moment
when you do find that courage and that
that happens after you and Shaun I mean
he effectively you guys are complete
completely kind of banishes you from the
family and you know
well I confronted my parents about my
sister and I both experienced something
with my brother and she told me that I
should confront my parents
I I decided I would so I did I told them
I thought it was an issue I thought we
need to deal with it and my father
decided that I was lying and he said I
was trying to destroy the family my
mother said maybe I was crazy that my
memories couldn't be trusted and that
was hard having me not believe me was
really hard but I think the hardest
thing really was after that they called
my brother and they told him everything
I had said and what followed after that
was a period of a lot of threats and he
would you know he called me and said
he'd hired an assassin to come kill me
these kinds of things and then he cut me
out of his life he disowned me and my
parents supported that decision and so
that Christmas they said you're not
allowed to come home because it'll make
your brother uncomfortable for the
reader I was most upset by your mother
in that situation I felt that there was
an opportunity there when you went and
kind of approached your mother about
these things and she seemed to be of
equal mind she had seen the things that
you she agreed with me at first we had a
chat actually it was online when she for
when I first started talking to her
about it and we had this chat where she
said yeah I I can see this now I of
course this has been happening and we're
gonna help you and we're gonna take care
of it and we're gonna get him into
therapy and we're gonna it's gonna be
okay
and she apologized to me she said that
she was sorry that she hadn't able to
keep us safe but when my father took the
position he did she she followed suit
this all culminates with a blessing that
your father offers you when you're at
Harvard and you you declined that
blessing can you unfortunately do not
have a lot of time a million questions
for you but alright will you talk to me
a little bit about about that cuz that
that to me I mean that's that's where
your kind of education comes full circle
and at first stage of the estrangement I
had for my parents was not by my choice
my brother cut me out of his life and my
parents supported it and I was
ostracized for 10 about 10 months and
then my I was doing a fellowship at
Harvard and my father came to visit me
with my mother which was surprising cuz
my dad hates traveling and he really
hates liberals
not an ideal place for him but he came
and he'd only been there with another
app as well right yeah he came and he
did not fit in but he came and they'd
only been there a few days before I
realized that they had come to offer me
away back into the family and what that
looked like was they had been telling
people and they believed the I was
possessed no that's why I had said these
things I had said about my brother and
so they were going to kind of offer me
this blessing as a kind of exorcism and
if I could just go along with it I could
say that I hadn't met any of the things
I said I could / can't effectively kind
of trade out their memories for mine and
I could have my family and there was a
period of a couple days at Harvard when
we were sightseeing around Boston
pretending like we're a happy family
when I kind of thought I could make that
bargain I thought it I thought it was a
pretty good deal and I was arguing with
myself I was trying to convince myself
that there was maybe some dignity in
denying my own memories in and my own
perceptions and that there was that I
was may be justified somehow and
surrendering what I knew to be true and
I really I really thought it was a deal
that I could make but the night before
they left back to Idaho my dad offered
me this blessing and I I couldn't I
couldn't do it and I think I think that
there were a couple things I realized in
that moment first thing I realized that
the the daughter that my father had come
to reclaim she just didn't exist anymore
I had gone off and I had gained whole
different perspectives I had a whole
different mind from all the studying I
had done and that that mind I had had no
tolerance for violence I couldn't I
couldn't surrender to it and it was
really clear to me of course I had been
the one that said it wasn't a demon that
said those things about my brother it
was me and what my father had come to
cast out of me it wasn't a demon it was
it was me I want to end this with a
final reading and at the end of the book
that I think brings us all full circle
and brings it back to kind of the
education that you were able to achieve
through this experience
just give me one second course i thought
i dog-eared it he but naturally I didn't
no matter how much I appeared to have
changed how illustrious my education how
altered my appearance I was still her at
best I was two people a fractured mind
she was inside and emerged whenever I
crossed the threshold of my father's
house that night I called on her and she
didn't answer she left me she stayed in
the mirror the decisions I made after
that moment were not the ones she would
have made they were the choices of a
changed person a new self you could call
this self had many things transformation
metamorphosis falsity betrayal I call it
an education thank you so much Tara my
pleasure thank you for writing this
exceptional book thank you